[Musique]
un autre panel ce soir José Legault
Émilie Nicolas et Alexandre à vous tous
bonjour
avant qu'on commence le bulletin c'est
le dévoilement du nom de celui qui va
avoir le poste de rapporteur spécial
indépendant donc nommé par le
gouvernement Trudeau pour faire la
lumière sur les allégations d'un gérant
chinoises mais aussi pour déterminer si
le gouvernement doit ou non lancer une
enquête publique alors on a appris que
c'est David Johnston c'est le 28e
gouverneur général du Canada il est en
fonction de 2010 à 2007 je vais
commencer par une tournée de réaction
José d'abord
on va l'appeler le rapporteur Royal je
pense
il a été nommé gouverneur général par
Steven Harper Premier ministre
conservateur donc c'est sûr que ça va
rendre la critique de sa nomination un
peu plus difficile c'est quand même
quelqu'un de très crédible qui a une
belle feuille de route mais on reste
quand même face à une stratégie de la
part du Premier ministre Trudeau qui
était essentiellement gagner du temps et
surtout de remettre entre les mains de
quelqu'un d'autre la décision délicate
de tenir ou pas une enquête publique sur
les gérants étrangères surtout chinoises
dans le processus démocratique au Canada
avec
en fait le fait qu'il était gouverneur
général c'est ce qu'on connaît le plus
de David Johnston mais c'est pas là le
petit croque en jambe au conservateur
c'est que c'est David Johnston qui avait
conseillé à l'époque en 2007 Steven
Harper pour créer la commission
souvenez-vous lorsque
les médias avaient-ils oui ou non
envoyer des enveloppes bourrées d'argent
comptable
obtenir un contrat à l'époque ou non
d'Airbus bref c'était très délicat pour
Steven Harper parce que on est ancien
Premier ministre conservateur ancien
chef de son parti alors il avait nommé
David Johnston qui est à l'époque un
professeur de droit était pas encore
gouverneur général comme conseiller
spécial c'est très très près du rôle de
rapporteur spécial pour dire qu'est-ce
que je devrais faire comme ça d'enquête
publique oui quel terme je devrais
mettre pour que la commission d'enquête
publique soit crédible et c'est le rôle
qui avait joué David Johnson donc lui
c'est clair que pour Pierre pour lièvre
il est conservateurs ça devient
compliqué de dire que c'est un mauvais
choix ils ont utilisé le même homme pour
lui mais leur partie à l'époque pour se
donner une crédibilité autour d'une
commission d'enquête publique alors
c'est là le petit croque engendre au
Parti conservateur qui va avoir plus de
difficultés à critiquer cette nomination
là il fait Émilie votre réaction
je pense que c'est vraiment l'intention
du gouvernement libéral avec cette
nomination là la seule chose que que
j'ajouterai c'est que on a vu en fait
déjà même si ça fait très peu de temps
que la réaction que la nomination pardon
a été annoncé que qui a pollièvre en
fait son
attaché essayer de réagir à la réaction
à la nomination en disant que bon
c'était pas le bon choix en s'attaquant
un certain des décisions que Monsieur
Johnson avait pris lorsqu'il était donc
une serre à la commission sur le débat
des chefs on sent qu'elle se croit pas
elle-même on sent que c'est
effectivement très difficile on sent que
ça sort du bout des lèvres et qu'elle ne
se convainc pas elle-même donc je pense
que sur ce coup là le gouvernement
réussi son coup après on verra pour
commencer va se dérouler qu'elle
recommandation ils vont faire parce que
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a parce que il
y a cette nomination là que le
gouvernement que ça m'a sorti de l'eau
chaude les réactions commencent à
rentrer on a celle du Bloc québécois le
chef du Bloc et François Blanchet je
vais vous le montrer à l'écran c'est un
tweet ce qu'on comprend de sa réaction
c'est qu'il en a pas contre le choix
mais il en a plutôt contre l'idée même
de pas passer tout de suite en enquête
publique alors c'est très loin de mon
écran je vais essayer de me pencher pour
le lire c'est écrit sans juger des états
de service de Monsieur Johnston on ne
peut que constater que je s'intrudo sans
tête à ne pas déclencher maintenant
l'enquête publique et indépendante que
tout le monde réclame d'ailleurs il faut
nous souligner José que les parties de
position mais ils ont pas participé au
choix de de ce monsieur le dans ce rôle
de rapporteur spécial au départ c'était
ça le plan de Justin Trudeau si on va
s'entendre tout le monde donc je vais
vous consulter puis on va choisir
quelqu'un qui ne fait pas des bas là qui
remporte uneanimité mais la réponse est
partie d'opposition ça a été c'est pas
ce qu'on veut on veut une enquête
publique de maintenant
oui mais il reste que c'est Justin
Trudeau qui est premier ministre du
Canada donc c'est lui qui apprend cette
décision là les parties d'opposition
peuvent s'opposer c'est c'est normal
mais encore une fois et je pense que la
réaction de François Blanchet le prout
c'est que la personne de David Johnson
est inattaquable et donc ça oblige les
chefs d'opposition à revenir sur Oui
mais on veut avoir une enquête publique
indépendante tout de suite
monsieur Trudeau le bon geste qui te
pose c'est justement en amant cette
personne là oui c'est un grand agent
c'est sûr aux particularité parce qu'il
y a mais c'est aussi donner une
crédibilité
à cet exercice là qui va débuter on sait
pas encore calme alors ce qu'on peut
dire mission accomplie est-ce que ça
habille à ce point-là Alex c'est-à-dire
monsieur Trudeau a réussi à retirer la
pression qu'il avait sur les épaules
dans ce dossier
non pas tout à fait c'est à dire que il
a trouvé une personne qui était
difficile à attaquer mais il a eu
beaucoup de temps pour la trouver ça
veut dire que probablement bien des
personnes qui ont refusé son offre avant
Davidson je ne suis pas certain qu'il
était le premier choix étant donné que
ça fait quoi maintenant à 10 jours au
moins qu'on a annoncé la présence de
rapporteur spécial donc on sent du côté
du gouvernement qu'on a quand même
encore de la pression pour être capable
de faire la lumière là-dessus mais on
joue un peu on joue l'horloge du côté du
gouvernement Trudeau dans cette histoire
là c'est à dire qu'on a pris beaucoup de
temps pour nommer le rapporteur spécial
maintenant on va le laisser faire son
travail la semaine prochaine qu'est-ce
qui va revenir l'attention Ottawa
l'arrivée du Joe Biden pendant deux
jours ça siège pas donc globalen va
prendre toute la place la semaine
d'après c'est le budget christia
Freeland donc c'est le budget qui va
retenir l'attention puis début avril
deux autres semaines de pause autour de
Pâques alors la pression elle ne viendra
pas des parties d'opposition elle va
venir peut-être d'autres révélations du
côté des médias elle va venir peut-être
d'une d'un comité parlementaire qui
réussit à faire siéger qui la chef de
cabinet de Justin Trudeau pour l'instant
les libéraux s'y oppose bec et ongles
font durer le temps de parole du côté du
comité parlementaire pour ne pas que le
témoin peut-être voici le réussir un
moment donné les parties de position à
la convoquée alors je pense qu'il va y
rester il va rester de la pression elle
ne va pas partir mais c'est acheter du
temps supplémentaire comme il le
souhaitait pour les prochaines semaines
avec la nomination David Johnston mais
aussi en jouant là avec le calendrier
byden le budget la relâche parlementaire
en espérant que bon ça se dégonfle un
peu tout ça je ne suis pas certain que
ça va se dégonfler mais je pense que
c'est ce que le gouvernement espère donc
au moins acheter du temps c'est un petit
peu sur l'objectif aussi de dire je
repousse ça là un petit peu plus tard on
parle de l'autre dossier qui est assez
intention aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
dans le dossier de la fonderie hordes à
Rouen n'aurenda donc création d'une zone
tampon mais on a vu les conséquences de
ça c'est 200 familles qui vont être
relocalisées ailleurs il y a des gens
d'ailleurs semble-t-il qu'ils ne veulent
pas déménager ça va se faire en grande
partie aux fraises du gouvernement le
goût qui va mettre 85 millions de
dollars là-dedans pour construire un
nouveau quartier l'annonce officielle
c'est demain mais déjà il y a des
réactions aujourd'hui parce que c'est
sorti dans quelques médias côté de
Québec solidaire on est tout à fait en
désaccord on écoute Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois
la zone tampon ne jamais fait partie de
la consultation le LACAQUE débarque avec
ses gros sabots et décide que pour
accommoder une entreprise milliardaire
on va déraciner 200 familles la vraie
priorité de la CAQ c'est pas la santé
des gens devant un agenda c'est
d'accommoder le plus possible la
fonderie
Emilie un petit peu plus tôt j'ai fait
une entrevue en direct avec une
représentante d'un comité citoyen qui
disait on a eu des consultations
publiques pas plus tard que cet automne
mais jamais il a été question de
délocaliser les gens les gens sont
surpris je vais vous entendre là-dessus
mais c'est sûr que je pense que tout le
Québec au complet est surpris donc en
plus si les gens eux-mêmes n'ont pas été
consultés je pense que sans beaucoup ça
sur la manière dont les choses se sont
faites essentiellement directement entre
la compagnie Denka et le gouvernement et
puis les gens ça passe après et dans ce
sens là même si on s'entend que c'est à
court terme effectivement le
gouvernement ne force pas la compagnie à
avoir des un taux de pollution aérienne
qui qui est sécuritaire à ce moment-là
c'est sûr que si les gens s'éloignent
dans ces conditions-là c'est pas mauvais
chose ceci dit ces conditions-là ne
devraient pas exister et j'ai
l'impression qu'on a à faire une
politique qui procurait pu en fait être
mise-bas dans les années 50 vraiment
l'idée que on accommode on fait tomber
on déplace où on arrange toute une ville
autour d'une compagnie plutôt que
d'arranger les compagnies l'industrie
pour servir les gens donc on est dans
une logique qui a prévalu au Québec
longtemps et c'est assez anachronique je
dirais d'avoir une nouvelle comme ça en
2023 c'est assez particulier et je dis
ça avec le recul de quelqu'un qui est
métamorial en fait j'aurais hâte d'en
savoir plus sur comment exactement les
gens sont en train de réagir à moins de
Randa parce que ça doit être une journée
très forte en émotion en fait il y a une
grande surprise c'est ce qu'on comprend
les gens qui sont un peu sous le choc
aujourd'hui José l'autre question c'est
pourquoi c'est le gouvernement qui met
85 millions là-dedans pourquoi c'est pas
glencoeur qui paye
ben c'est ce qui moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Emilie c'est c'est ce qui
fait qu'on se sent un peu propulsé en
arrière vers une autre époque parce que
au Québec
est particulièrement docile face à
l'industrie des ressources naturelles
face à des grosses grosses compagnies on
a regardé la filière minière
c'est ça c'est c'est finalement
l'insulte suprême d'une certaine manière
parce que
greenko en effet est une multinationale
multimilliardaire il n'y a aucune raison
que que seul dollar de fonds publics
aillent dans ce qui va être fait en plus
que ce qui va être fait
confirme que il y a un danger à la santé
à tous ces gens-là sinon on ne voudrait
pas les délocaliser ça c'est très très
clair et ça pour moi le le danger dans
tout ça c'est que non seulement ça
confirme qu'il y a danger mais en
qui va racheter les immeubles qui vont
aller démolir il faut créer la zone
tampon à laverdissant donc quand même un
impact financier mais la relocalisation
la création de nouveaux quartiers c'est
vrai que le gouvernement qui va payer
pour ça vous savez c'est un dossier
assez complexe parce qu'il y a aussi des
gens qui veulent quitter cette zone là
ce quartier là Notre-Dame et que leur
maison à peu près plus de valeur de la
présence de la fonderie qui vont
probablement être contents que
maintenant quelqu'un rachète leur
propriété qui puisse déménager ailleurs
parce que sinon il est incapable de le
faire alors il y a des gens qui voudront
pas partir il y a des gens qui vont
vouloir partir et qui sont bien contents
faudra que la compensation soit juste et
à la base c'est qu'on a on est en train
d'essayer de faire ce qu'on aurait dû
faire à l'époque c'est-à-dire ne pas
permettre à des gens de venir
s'installer à côté d'une fonderie parce
qu'elle était là la fonderie avant que
les gens s'installent autour et on le
voit sur les images
qu'on avait pas 50 ans on parlait des
années 50 mais non 70 ans maintenant on
avait pas nécessairement les mêmes
connaissances sur la santé publique les
risques les dangers etc et là donc on
est en train d'essayer de corriger cette
erreur historique ça se fait en grinçant
des dents c'est bien évident il y a des
qui seront pas contents il y en a qui
sont pas heureux mais vous savez on le
fait à malarticle pas très loin de là on
a déplacé des maisons on a déplacer des
résidents parce qu'on a créé une mine
d'or à l'époque on a l'expérience en
Abitibi pour si on veut réussir cette
opération-là bien la faire regrouper les
gens négocier collectivement avec Glenn
individuellement ça ce serait une erreur
vous donner un rapport de force exiger
des choses aussi de la part du
gouvernement parce que dans le nouveau
quartier il va y avoir du transport en
commun est-ce qu'on peut créer des
écoles est-ce qu'on peut créer des
maisons de personnes âgées là faut se
donner du côté des citoyens le gros bout
du bâton pour négocier c'est faisable
ils l'ont fait avec Madame mais oui il y
a beaucoup d'embûches puis il va y avoir
des insatisfaits ça c'est ça c'est
inévitable dans ce type d'opération très
délicate alors je rappelle que l'annoncé
oui
José mais merci qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu
des fonds publics qui sont allés
là-dedans je pense pas
la mine de payer ouais c'est ça
mais c'est pas vous c'est le premier
ministre qui se lance dans l'animation
de balados ça s'appelle bonjour tout le
monde sa première invitée c'est Régine
Laurent pour voir ce que ça donne
bonjour tout le monde
bonjour et je ne Laurent bonjour
monsieur Lego merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté de participer donc au premier
balado
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça
un premier ministre vous savez en
Alberta Jessie Kenny Daniel Smith on
leur émission de radio hebdomadaire à
Calgary là on est rendu du Premier
ministre il y avait donc Ford à
l'Ontario qui avait à l'époque tenté de
créer sa chaîne de nouvelle gérée par le
parti c'est pas nouveau que les
politiciens essaient de tenir le micro
il n'aime pas trop trop répondre à des
questions alors s'ils sont capables les
poser c'est plus le fun pour les autres
François Legault je pense est beaucoup
plus à l'aise dans le rôle du Premier
ministre dans celui d'interviewer donc
peut-être qu'il va s'habituer on verra
bien mais c'est toujours cette idée
d'essayer de présenter un politicien qui
soit Premier ministre qui soit ministre
qui soit députés dans un rôle un peu
différent de celui qu'on est habitué de
voir à la télé dans un conférence de
presse dans un discours humanisé un
petit peu le politicien montrer qu'il a
d'autres intérêts la culture le sport la
lecture les débats de société je suis
pas certain que François Legault avait
besoin de ça bien honnêtement c'est
quelqu'un de populaire déjà perçu près
d'être très des gens c'est pas comme
Steven Harper à l'époque qui avait créé
la chaîne 24 7 pour l'humaniser un peu
parce qu'elle a l'air froid les mêmes
enjeux alex je veux qu'on aille tout de
suite dans un autre dossier parce que le
temps filtre est très vite et l'autre
sujet qui fait jaser cette publicité
qu'on veut écouter ensemble
cet oiseau de poivre vraiment sick des
reconnus pour être assez chill parce
qu'il est super couic en vol il peut
passer la majorité de son temps à Watch
et son environnement mais malgré leur
publicité pour faire la promotion de la
qualité de la langue française et non
pas utilisé du franglais comme on le
fait dans cette annonce José votre
réaction est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on le
fait de la bonne façon pour développer
l'amour de la langue et le respect de la
langue
gros malaise de ma part en tout cas
peut-être parce que je travaille le
dossier de la langue française au Québec
depuis 30 ans et que j'analyse son
déclin malheureusement depuis tout ça là
écoutez il y a deux choses pour moi tire
là-dessus c'est premièrement je pense
pas qu'on va convaincre les jeunes de
faire un petit peu plus attention puis
là j'aime pas cette généralisation là
les jeunes parce que c'est deux dont sa
femme finalement dans cette publicité là
ça fera anglais là en ce moquant deux
d'une certaine manière bon et la
deuxième chose c'est que vous savez même
si on avait des publicités réalisées par
Denis Villeneuve je ne sais trop il y a
rien de ça qui va aider à freiner le
déclin de la langue française c'est un
problème beaucoup plus grave que ça
beaucoup plus dramatique et ça nous
laisse un peu sur notre fin
stratégie finalement avec la langue
j'aimerais entendre Émilie parce que ça
a l'air cool comme on dirait
pour parler français
il y a le franglais ça a ses règles on
écrit mais ça a ses règles le chien ça a
ses règles quand
ça s'entend tout de suite la différence
entre quelqu'un qui parle anglais et
quelqu'un qui est un bonhomme qui se
moque des jeunes qui parlent anglais et
là l'annonce est scriptée de manière qui
n'est pas authentique du tout alors ça
paraît et ça paraît donc ça ça pour vous
c'est resté c'est ce que je comprends
la volonté qui parle comme ça il y a
personne qui parle comme ça on va se
laisser là-dessus merci pour le mot de
la feuille merci à eux pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI